Donald Trump has just announced that he
has been informed he has been indicted
by the federal government by Biden's doj
relating to the classified documents in
his home this coming on a day when a new
report has come out showing that Joe
Biden received a bribe to fire the
Ukrainian prosecutor from someone in
barisma or I I want to make sure we're
very careful and very clear we've got
what appears to be FBI confirmation that
Joe Biden was bribed the bribery is
related to firing the prosecutor what
many people long suspected or believed
we got a lot of big breaking news to
talk about Donald Trump being indebted a
second time he'll likely be indebted a
third time in Georgia and then we have
the Rhonda Sanders campaign using AI
images of Trump trump hugging and
kissing Dr fauci now to be honest that
one's substantially less consequential
than the others but it does pertain to
the election and everything so I think
we should bring it up